- the last bulk of the morning session
our speaker is Reema Inari that is from
Stanford and also I think currently at
the assignments he's in the talk about
some Johnny Walker with Cheyenne and
safety inside that is work on accounting
intersection B so this is joint work
with echo so this is a joint work with
China and Cynthia and most of the talk
is gonna be about a mate Roy a framework
to count basis of Metroid's and common
basis of tomatoes so the the high-level
picture of what we are gonna do is to
study mate roids with their shadows okay
so I don't know if you've seen these
puzzles before but I used to do this
back when I was an undergrad a lot you
you're given shadows of an object and
you're asked to guess what the object is
so of course the shadows don't always
have enough information for you to
reconstruct the entire thing but you can
gain a lot of information from the
shadows so for example if you have a
shape like this and you want to compute
its volume what you can do is you can
project it onto the coordinate axes and
you get one dimensional shadows like
this and based on just these two shadows
you can just put a bounding box around
your shape and the volume of this
bounding box bounds the volume of the
shape so the volume of the bounding box
basically gives you an upper bound on
the volume of the shape so so you can do
this no matter what you'll get an upper
bound and you can do this much more
generally and in a much more
sophisticated way using these think
these things called brass count leave
inequalities and there are many other
inequalities of the same flavors such as
entropy subadditivity and shears lemma
and so on so this talk is about one of
these inequalities that has this slavery
okay so entropy selectivity and the
question is you
always get an upper bound by studying
the shadows when is this upper bound
close to actually the the thing that you
want to study okay so in this example
the volume we are approximating the
volume of our shape by is up is off by a
factor of two imagine that there could
be like something of volume zero for
which you're actually outputting a
volume a positive volume so okay so this
is the this is the general setting we're
going to be studying you have a discrete
problem so you have a subset of the
hypercube let's say a bunch of binary
vectors and you can for most of the talk
I'm just going to take the hyper cube to
be isomorphic to the subsets of one
through n so you have a collection of
these things and we want to approximate
the cardinality of this set so so an
alternative way of computing this this
cardinality is by computing the entropy
of an Associated distribution so if you
let mu be the uniform distribution and
on this collection or in particular on
any collection the entropy of this
distribution mu which is defined like
this you just sum over all points inside
of your support the probability times
log of the inverse probability so this
thing becomes the log of the support
size for for for any uniform
distribution so computing this
cardinality is the same as computing
this entropy and so more generally we
are going to be studying distributions
on on the hypercube and we want to study
whether we can compute the entropy of
these distributions by studying shadows
of the solution so what do I mean by
shadows if you have any distribution on
the hypercube you can look at its
marginals so basically look at the
components of a vector-valued random
variable that's distributed according to
MU each of the components is just a zero
one random variable
so these are the one-dimensional shadows
of this n-dimensional vector and we just
want to study what's the relationship
between the entropy of the distribution
and the entropy of these shadows these
shadows are presumably much simpler to
deal with because they're just very
random variables so so that's the
motivation so you can compute these
shadows and you can also compute they're
on trapeze they're just given by this
formula right and similar to to the to
the bounding box volume you also have
some additive 'ti of entropy which says
that the entropy of this entire
distribution is bounded by the sum of
the entropies of the one-dimensional
shadows so if you knew the marginals of
this distribution you could easily get
an upper bound on there on the entropy
of you feel free to ask any questions if
not so so the question is you always get
this upper bound but when is this upper
bound actually a good approximation when
is it a good so so there there is
actually there are actually two
questions one is that when is this
when is the gap in this inequality
basically not too large
when is this a good approximation and
the other thing which I'm going to
address much later in the talk is
whether actually this upper bound we can
compute it all right so what we are
interested in is is is is fast
algorithms or polynomial time algorithms
and it's not clear that we can compute
this upper bound because computing
marginals there is no obvious way to do
it but let me address the first one
first so so this inequality is actually
yeah just this these special
yeah yeah yeah so we're not gonna be
doing anything with sheer Islam or
anything like that yeah okay so so okay
so first let's see when this gap is
known to be small so when the when the
distribution that you have is a product
distribution the two sides are actually
equal to each other and that's the only
case where equality happens but you know
there are things which are not exactly
product distributions but for which the
gap is still small for example consider
the distribution over all size size K
subsets of 1 through n okay as n goes to
infinity this way this basic the two
sides are asymptotically the same so
there are some cases where the two sides
are very very far apart so this is maybe
a canonical example you have a
distribution supported on just two
vectors one of these vectors is one on
the first half of the coordinates 0 in
the second half the other one is 0 in
the first half of coordinates 1 on the
rest right so for this distribution the
marginals are as if this was a truly
uniformly random distribution and the
entire hypercube right from the
marginals you can't distinguish this
from the product distribution but
obviously the support size here is 2 or
as a support size of the entire
hypercube is like 2 to the n so the gap
is very very large
but in this stock I'm going to be
focusing on very special sets basis of
am a trade or common basis of to my
choice and I'm going to be showing that
basically we won't be in this case the
gap would would not be too large you
won't be as close as these two these two
cases but it won't be too large either
so so back to the second question of
when can we actually compute this even
if we knew that the the gap was small
it's not clear that we can compute the
right-hand side and in fact we can't you
know for for at least self reducible
problems computing these marginals is
just as hard as the counting problem
itself that Mister but there is a there
is a trick that we are going to be using
the trick is that even though we don't
know what what the actual marginal
values are we know some some basically
basic constraints that they have to
satisfy in particular if you look at
these P I values which are the
probabilities of having one coordinates
these are just these are just the
averages of the points inside your
distribution so these are just an
average of the support of your
distribution and in particular they lie
inside the convex hull of the
distribution the convex hull of the
support of the distribution so if you if
you only care about an upper bound you
could take a more pessimistic upper
bound and just you know over this
feasible region which you might have
more access to try to see what's the
worst possible thing that you can get on
the right hand side the maximum of the
sum of the margins and this just by
definition this still gives you an upper
bound on the entropy of your
distribution and now this thing might be
more easily computable at least in the
case of Metroid so I'll show you why
this is computed and what we are going
to be showing is that even though we are
taking a more pessimistic upper bound
the gap is still not too much
so yeah so the good the only good thing
about taking this more this worst case
upper bound is that it only requires
computation over or it only requires us
to be able to optimize over the convex
hull and formate roads we know how to do
that so this is this is the entire
framework for whatever subset of 0 1 to
the N we're just gonna try to maximize
the sum of the marginal entropies
subject to these pis being inside the
convex hull
so let me let me now switch to tomato
and tell you a little bit about what
they are so mate roads are basically an
abstraction of the notion of linear
independence and this is basically the
most useful example that you should you
should think of when you think of matrix
so imagine that you have a bunch of
vectors and the subsets so these are n
vectors and the subsets that you're
looking at out of these n objects are
the subsets that are linearly
independent okay so for example these
three vectors out of these six are
linearly independent you can list all
independent sets of size three these are
all of them you can list independent
sets of size two these are all of them
and so on right and these these
independent sets always satisfy certain
axioms which when you abstract out gives
you the definition of main troy's so a
mate right is basically a collection of
subsets of 1 through n which satisfies
exactly two axioms one is downward
closure when you have an independent set
any smaller set is still independent
which is automatically satisfied by
linear independence but the more
important one is this exchange axiom
which says that if you have two
independent sets and one is larger than
the other one there is one element of
the larger set that you can add to the
smaller one and still be independent so
in other words this is saying that you
can't put k plus 1 linearly independent
vectors in a subspace of dimension K
so so this exchange axiom automatically
says that the the maximal independent
sets must all have the same size we knew
that from the from the linear case they
all hat must have the same the size the
dimension of the ambient space and these
are called the basis of the Metroid B
and this is exactly the the collection
that we want to count and the only
assumption we have on metroid is the
only computational assumptions we have a
Metroid is that we have an Oracle that
tells us if a set is independent or not
so it's very well known that this is
very this is equivalent to a to much
stronger Oracle's computationally so in
particular having just access to this
Oracle you can you can maximize linear
functions over independent sets and in
particular you can optimize over the
convex hull of the independent sets or
the bases so so yeah so if you only have
access to this independence or a call
pretty much you can do optimization you
can even do optimization over over the
common basis of two matrix so it's so if
you have two matrix one with basis B 1 1
with basis B 2 something magical happens
which is that the intersection of the
convex hulls is the convex hull of the
common basis so because you can you can
optimize over this convex hull and you
can optimize over this convex all you
can also optimize over the convex hull
of the intersection so you can not you
can you can optimize over convex hulls
of mate choice and you can optimize over
convex hulls of intersections of my
choice but when it goes to counting the
picture gets murkier so until very
recently we didn't know whether we can
actually count the number of bases of a
mate choice so a result of Federer and
Mihai I think the
result of feather and Mihai from almost
30 years ago showed that you can count
basis of a mate right bases are very
special men Troy's up to a 1 plus
epsilon factor very recently we showed
that you can actually do this for all my
rhoids and but but but when it comes to
deterministic algorithms the picture is
very very much incomplete so so let me
just tell you a little bit about some of
these other results that I've written
here so Sasha and summer it Mitsuki they
actually came up with a with an
algorithm that doesn't care about may
Troy des it just works for for any set B
over which you can still do optimization
okay so the Mon downside of their
algorithm is that it's randomized and
we're just this workshop is about
deterministic counting but it actually
gives you a pretty good approximation so
it gives you in the worst case it gives
you a log into the rank approximation so
the approximation factor is a little bit
harder to explain this is like the worst
possible case better case is better yes
so so yeah so yeah it would have taken
me a full slide to explain what this
approximation factor but yeah but this
is yeah so when it comes to
intersections of Metroid's we pretty
much only know things about a very
particular special case and that's
perfect matchings in a bipartite graph
as we've seen in the in many talks in
this workshop that's that's the
intersection of tomatoes in particular
to partition matrix and for that special
case celebrated result of German
Sinclair and Vigoda shows that you can
you can use randomization to do 1 plus
epsilon approximate counting for
deterministic counting we are still very
far off the only kind of approximation
we know is exponential
so so let me switch back to an example
and see what our weather marginal
entropies say to get a better feeling
okay so so a very very typical case of a
metroid is spanning trees in a graph so
here is a graph the complete graph on
four vertices if you look at forests or
basically subsets of edges which don't
have a cycle they form independent sets
of a Metroid and bases of this matron
are just spanning trees okay so so so
this graph has 16 spanning trees and
I've drawn all of them here okay
the shadows of this maitreya we're going
to be looking at are just you know for a
particular edge what's the probability
of this edge being inside a randomly
chosen spanning tree so so for this span
for this particular edge there are
exactly eight spanning trees that
contain it so the probability of it
being contained in a spanning tree is
just one half in general for spanning
trees you can you can compute this these
marginal probabilities using using
inverses of laplacian and so on but for
for general Metroid's this is hard all
right so yeah so so okay so let's let's
do a calculation so if you know that the
each edge has a probability of 1/2 of
being in a randomly chosen spanning tree
then the marginal entropy of each edge
is exactly one one bit of information
and you have six edges so the total the
total upper bound you get on the entropy
of the randomly chosen spanning trees
would be six bits or in other words you
would get an upper bound of 64 two to
the six on the number of spanning trees
so it's not particularly tight but it's
not also very far off on how you
so so so this is what we can show that
the the upper bound we had before which
was the numerator on the right hand side
is is actually a lower bound if you
divided by a factor of two so in the
previous case we had six bits of
information if you divide that by two
you get three bits of information and so
that gives you a lower bound of eight on
the number of stages yeah so for this
particular case you get that the number
of spanning trees must be between 8 and
64 I in particular this this 8 can also
be tight you can easily construct the
graph where something like this
this craft still has six edges each one
of its edges participates in half of the
spanning trees and the number of
spanning trees here is a the one can
also be tight so now I just want to show
you a sketch of the proof of this fact
so so what you want to show is that the
twice the entropy of the spanning tree
distribution is at least sum of the
entropies of the marginals the marginals
are just Bernoulli random variables so
I've just written down what they're
distribute what they're marginals what
they're entropies look like and you can
just split this into two sums the one
over the P log 1 over P and 1 minus P
log 1 1 over 1 minus it's enough to show
that basically the entropy of the
distribution is at least each summand
individually that's what we are going to
show so here is here is where the
connection to this workshops to this
program comes in we're gonna do that
based on properties of the generating
polynomial of this this distribution or
in particular the generating polynomial
of spanning trees so so for any for any
subset of 0 1 to the N you can define a
poem you know where you basically have
this should be n sorry you have n
variables corresponding to your n
elements and for each subset you just
multiply the variables in that subset
and you sum this over all subsets in
your collection so this is a multi
affine problem you know that you get so
something something magical happens for
spanning trees and also for all of my
retreats and that thing is that this
formula is law concave if you look at it
as a function over the positive or not
so for spanning trees there are there
are very easy proofs of this but we've
seen also this happen for for other
Metroid in may be previous workshops and
I'll get a little bit more to to why
this happens later on but but for now I
assume this ok so this formula is just
la concave and what we're going to do is
apply yen sense in you
to this party so Jensen's inequality
says that if I put in a random point the
expectation of the value at the random
point is upper bounded by the value at
the expectation okay so I just need to
define a random point and plug it into
the answers inequality and see what I
get
okay so the random points there is a
fairly natural choice for a random point
you can just plug in the the indicator
of a random spanning tree or Oris or the
or or an element in your distribution
okay so the problem with with that
choice is that when you when you compute
the expected value of of your random
point you get a you get a beard vector
you get exactly so if X was basically
chosen according to mu then yam X would
be the vector of all the marginals right
but we what we want is not to evaluate
palm oil at this at this particular
point but what we want is to evaluate
the palm y at the point all once because
that gives us the number of spanning
trees so there is a there is a very easy
trick to to deal with this you just
scale each of the coordinates by just
the expectation so that the expected
value becomes double ones vector so if
you just define Y to be that scaling now
expectation of Y is just the Allman's
vector and so the left hand side of the
instance inequality just becomes log of
the number of spanning trees or the
number of sets in your collection
so what about the right hand side so for
the right hand side when you plug in a
scale indicator of a spanning tree all
of the terms in this polynomial vanish
except for that particular spanning tree
and for that particular spanning tree
what you are going to get is just one
over the product of these probabilities
these are just the scaling factors that
we put in and you're just taking the
average of log of this thing now you're
now here you have a log of a product so
you can just be compose it into a sum of
logs and you can just see how many times
an edge he appears inside of this sum
and that's that's exactly this fraction
PE the marginal of that AG so ya so on
the right hand side you get exactly what
we wanted good left hand side or the
first cement here so we just got that
the the log of the number of spanning
trees is at least this much if you look
at the complements of spanning trees and
you repeat the same proof what you're
gonna get is that the the entropy of the
complement of spanning trees is is
exactly bigger than the right hand side
but you know when you when you
complement spanning trees that the
entropy of the distribution doesn't
change right you're just looking at the
same number of collections the the same
number of sets in your collection
so so the moral of the story is that
whenever you have a distribution who's
generating polynomial is la concave you
can prove this entreprenuer but whenever
you have this distribution mute doesn't
matter if it's uniform or not as long as
this polynomial which encodes mu into
the coefficients as long as this is LA
concave the entropy of MU is lower
bounded by the sum of Pi log 1 over P I
so so this this gives you a factor two
approximation in the case of spanning
trees but if you if you care about
additive approximations you can also
compute what's the gap between the two
sides of this inequality okay so if you
add in these terms the 1 minus P log 1
over 1 minus PS you get an upper bound
so the gap between the two sides can be
at most this right and just you know
term by term this is smaller than then
each one of these is just smaller than P
I and so you get you get that the
additive gap between the two sides of
this inequality is that most of some of
the PI's and for Metroid some of the
PI's is a known quantity it's just the
cardinality of the sets that you're
looking at each P I is just the
probability that that element I is
inside the randomly chosen set so the
sum of them would be the expected size
of a randomly chosen set and form a
troice this is exactly the rank or the
cardinality of the bases of the matrix
so so yeah so this this gives you
basically that from marginals you can
compute an a2 to the rank approximation
to the number of bases so one ingredient
that was very crucial here was little
concavity of this polynomial and you
know back when we were working on this
under sin equality we didn't have a very
good handle on this so we had to look at
like sources of generating random
generating basically lock and key
formulas so one of the well-known
sources are determinants and in general
real stable Paulo meals whenever you
have a bunch of PST increases if you
summed up if you scale each one by a
variable Zi and you sum them up and you
take the determinant you get a lock on
kpop more generally whenever you have a
real stable form you know which is the
case for determinants you get lock on
cavity and spanning trees you could you
can easily handle by by determinants
spanning tree polynomials can be written
as a determinant of this one so another
special lock on K for our volume for
meals so so when you have a bunch of
convex sets if you scale each one of
them by a factor is the eye and if you
take their minkovski sum and take the
volume at the end this also becomes law
concave so law concavity of this is
known as the blooming cough skinny
equality
but you know not all my toys can be
captured in these two ways and we looked
around and we found out that there are
these inequalities in hodge theory
called hajiman relations and they also
always give you luck on kpop so so using
basically a very recently developed
theory by at the proceed to Han Katz who
basically proved these hajiman relations
for formate roids we managed to show
that for all matrices this polynomial is
LA concave so in previous workshops we
have actually seen more direct proofs of
this and I'm not gonna repeat those but
now we have a good handle of we actually
have basically a complete machinery to
check whether a given polynomial X lock
on keyboard and this machinery in may
see maybe half a page of math gives you
low concavity of these problems so okay
so all right so so far what I've said is
that if you have the marginals of a
distribution or the uniform distribution
on mate roids you can count the number
of the bases okay up to up to certain
approximations but back to the
computational problem we can't actually
compute the marginal probabilities very
easily in fact Metroid's of self
reducible so it's computing marginals is
just as hard as counting but we're just
gonna do what I said earlier which is to
take a pessimistic bound
okay so just reiterating we're just
looking at the convex hull of all of the
bases or the indicators of bases we know
that the vector of P is is going to be
some point inside here it's the average
of all of the vertices exactly and
instead of finding this average exactly
we're just going to see what's the worst
case of this sum of marginal entropy is
over this entire polity
so so so yeah so if you if you don't
look at the basically one-dimensional
marginals if you look at like marginals
on like higher subsets the the polytope
that you get you can't optimize over it
it's actually hard to optimize over it
for certain so yeah so form a troit at
least I don't know how to go beyond
one-dimensional margins presumably if
you have a problem where you can where
you can look at maybe pairwise marginals
as a vector and like the feasibility
region is you can optimize over that
maybe maybe that gives you a better
approximation but for matrix that's and
it's in the full generality it's not
possible and yeah so so we only need a
separation or echo and for Metroid's we
have a separation Oracle over the
smaller table so we can compute this
this this quantity the objective is just
a concave function we can separate this
part of everything that's fine but why
is this more pessimistic bound still
good
well the upper bound is still automatic
for for whatever set be the upper bound
still holds but but I want to show you
that even this more pessimistic bound
when your palm is locked concave is
still the same it still gives you all of
the same approximations I proved for the
true margins so the main the main
insight is that there is going to be a P
maximizing this objective okay it's not
the vector of three marginals but but
there is actually going to be so because
this P is inside the convex how there's
going to be some distribution on the set
of basis that gives you exactly these
marginals it's not the uniform
distribution but some distribution okay
so let's say that's the distribution new
and you can even put more structure on
you if you if among all distributions
new which
marginals PU look at the one that has
the maximum possible entropy it's going
to be up this form where the product
where the probability of a particular
base B is going to be the product of a
bunch of lambda i's where lambdas are
just a vector I've confused all of the
ends with ends so m's ends and ends are
all the same so the probability of a
base is just the product of the lambda
i's and these are just some numbers that
come out of the do all of max entropy
optimization for this distribution you
we can also compute its generating
polynomial it's related to the giant
economy of the uniform distribution or
the distribution mu that we started if
you just scale each one of the variables
Z by the particular lambda I you're
gonna get exactly the distribution
coming up for new up to some scaling and
if this polynomial is about concave this
this sort of scaling of the input
preserves not concavity new is also
going to have a generating formula which
is la concave and and so all of the
previous inequalities we proved are
satisfied for new as well well you know
among all distributions on the set P the
uniform distribution has the maximum
entropy right so the entropy of the
uniform distribution B is going to be an
upper bound on the distribution mu and
for because nu has a lock on KL we still
could get this lower bound for it so
even though this p is not the true
vector of marginals we can still prove
the same border so so the moral of the
story is that if you compute that convex
relaxation exponentiate the result or
the objective you're gonna have this
number alpha which has two types of
guarantees it's a square root
approximation to the number of bases
it's also a 2 to the rank approximation
it's an additive gap inside the inside
the entropy now becomes a multiplicative
cap a multiplicative gap in entropy now
becomes the power so this is also not
very far from but what you can prove Li
you can prove is not achievable so
almost twenty years ago as our Broder
and freeze showed that if you are
considering deterministic algorithms in
the model where you only have access to
your Metroid through an Oracle you can't
actually get any algorithm better than
this in polynomial time
so after this log squared n which
appears in the in the exponent this is
almost type yeah so this is basically an
information theoretic lower bound it
just uses the fact that there are just
too many Metroid's on a set of n
elements so if you if you query only
Palmilla many points you there's still
like a lot of room for you to change the
main troy'd and and screw the algorithm
basically so so very surprisingly the
same algorithm the same convex
relaxation works for the intersection of
two mate weeds as well we don't get this
type of an up of a guarantee but we get
this type of a guarantee so so the
reason that you get you get this stuff
for the intersection of two matrix is
basically based on another capacity
inequality building upon the work of
leonid you can basically form a palm yo
so here we have two mate roads which
sets up basis B 1 and B 2 you can form a
matron form a power meal in in two sets
of variables Y's and Z's where I'm just
summing over pairs of B 1 from B 1 B 2
from B 2 and I'm taking the product of
elements in B 1 and elements not in B 2
ok so in matrix language this is
basically the direct sum of this is the
direct sum of the metroid m1 with
basically the dual of the metroid m2 so
this is a polynomial it's still a
metroid polynomial because these
operations that are that we're doing
through the matrix they preserve my
treatments so in particular this formula
is still not concave the quantity we
want to study is the number of common
bases you can express that as some form
of and of a differential operator
applied to this polynomial G so so I'm
just going to take partial y plus
partial Z I and then apply I'll apply
this for all I to the power G and then
set all of the Vice and Z's to 0 ok so
the reason that you get the number of
common bases is that when you want to
evaluate this expression from each one
of these parentheses you have to choose
either partial Y I or partial Z I write
the choice of partial Y is basically
signifying that you're you're taking the
element I to be in the common basis and
the choice of partial Z I is basically
signifying that you're not taking that
element to be in the common basis and
for whatever choices you make over these
parties and these end parenthesis you
only get a nonzero term if the if that
choice is compatible with a base from
both matrix
yeah so when you expand the South you
exactly get the number of common bases
and these operations that we are doing
to this formula they're also very much
compatible with la concavity we can we
can show that basically not only is this
formula concave but after you apply a
bunch of directional derivatives in
positive directions then you still have
la concavity and this we first proved it
using exactly the same Hodge Theory
proven for matrix so so so basically
everything is ready for you to apply
where it says method and get a capacity
inequality and this is exactly what we
did for for any LOC concave follow me Oh
after you apply a bunch of partial
derivatives like that and you set the
variables to zero you can compare what
you get to basically the result of an
optimization problem which is a capacity
like a new college capacity like
quantity okay so so the extra terms that
you get here so these things also the P
I to the P is they also appear in the in
the original capacity inequalities these
extra things coming from block concavity
so so the method to prove such a thing
is basically the same as the the
original capacity inequalities
everything basically everything
basically tenderizes you you can just
prove this using induction on M or M and
everything reduces to basically
bivariate formula so you only have to
check this for apology of y&z
you know we are we are also in the realm
of just multi affine polynomials so so a
bivariate polynomial like this is just
going to be a plus B Y plus cz Plus D Y
Z right and the only thing that you need
to use about la concavity is that for
these coefficients this inequality is
satisfied ad is basically at most twice
PC so so from justice inequality you can
prove this for this special case of
bivariate formulas and then just using
the machinery of of gravity you can
basically generally do to all to all
numbers of variables so okay so so this
constant here the thing here in the case
of real stability it's something like
this
so in the case of la concavity you get
an extra factor of I think so it's most
likely the instead of pi/2 VI would be
some kind of factorial answer and
instead of that e will be one minus P to
the power 1 yes
so I basically use the same inequality I
had before which is that 1 minus P log
of 1 over 1 minus P is less than
basically P to replace that by e to the
P but in this case probably this case
written is kind of a little bit simple
because you can reduce it if I'm not
mistaken to the 1 to the one manone no
we're doing change your variables okay
understand them the original equality
will exist you know polynomial and you
go of the specific condition yeah which
you which means that you differentiate
respect x1 so here you differentiate
respect to linear forms yeah so again
you can do change your variables which
also will preserve that strong low
concave it that is true but then the
quantities that appear here are not
going to be of this form yes yeah so
they in some cases they will be better
okay okay so what does this have to do
with the convex program that we have so
basically if you just take logs of all
of the sides what you get is this
inequality on the top line right and you
can basically look at this capacity and
equal this capacity like quantity so so
everything basically separates out over
over when basically your palm oil is a
product of two polynomials which is the
case in our in our setting this this
capacity basically separates out you can
form it as as some quantity about the
Metroid m1
some quantity about the Metroid m2 and
these quantities are just on trapeze so
capacity is the same as the capacity
when when these powers the powers of the
variables and the denominator are just
some vector P this is the same as the
entropy of the max entropy distribution
with those marginal speak so in other
words what I'm saying is that this this
quantity appearing here is just the
entropy of that distribution new that we
had which had exactly marginals so so we
can basically appropri place this
quantity here by the sum of the marginal
entropies of p is right which is what
i've what i've done here and we can
replace the quantity here again by the
sum of the marginals of pies and one set
of these pis is going to basically
cancel out this one the p to the PS that
appear in the in the capacity inequality
and so you still get the you still get
basically that the entire thing is lower
bounded by the sum of Pi log one of our
pies up to an additional fact additional
additive term of order blank
so so now let me conclude since I'm over
time so yeah so I just showed you a very
simple algorithm to get a deterministic
approximation to the number of basis of
a Metroid and common basis of two matrix
so one of the one of them may be useful
things about this sort of an
approximation is that you can actually
boost it to get a 1 plus epsilon
approximation so this is due to very
classical results due to German Sinkler
whenever you have an approximation you
can you can pay that approximation
factor in the running time and up to
using randomization you get a 1 plus
epsilon factor upwards yeah I think this
is currently the best the best thing we
know for for Metroid intersections so
you get a you get an algorithm with
whose running time is 2 to the old rank
which is better than n to the over and
you know you can you can apply this
framework of optimizing the sum of the
marginal entropies to other problems as
well whenever you have a polytope you
can optimize over and you can just
compute this quantity in particular the
polytope of all perfect matchings in a
non bipartite graph is a is an important
special case and maybe maybe maybe this
approximation is is tight in the same
sense as as may true it's that it gives
you a 2 to the n approximation to the
number of perfect matchings in an envoy
[Applause]
new questions
I'll throw in another wild one
so subadditivity is very useful have you
thought about strong some activity what
do you mean by strength of an activity
someone who I really or or strong
subadditivity says that if you instead
of taking the product into spaces and
saying that the entropy of that is
smaller than the sum of the entities
take three okay and you can look at the
entropy of the whole thing and the
entropy of one of them that some some of
those two entropy again to be the whole
thing and actually if one of them any
one you like more than the end that's
our modularity huh is that useful for
anything so sub majority of entropy is
very useful for for things like here is
lemma for example but well you know the
only thing we have a handle on are just
one dimension trapeze right in this
framework at least so so so we can't
because we can't get our hands on
basically pairwise marginals
or any higher-order marginals I I
currently don't think that that would
help in any way with this frame if there
is a problem where we have basically
yeah where we can look at the polytope
of pairwise marginals or maybe three
ways marginals or anything like that
then some modularity would help you to
get the to get an upper bound in terms
of those margins
again slight little first equation so
imagine you have dissipation that you
helped promote them algorithm to compute
all fighters finite dimensional
distribution of given cake so all K okay
just president by some magic because
this situation can you use the donor
code maybe some item like some mulled
wine whatever can use the Torah code -
that's a good question I don't know by
the way Alicia hope to cookies you come
this approach you will know what the
problem is working on the building the
last one oh my question is in other
dimensions of modularity so entropy is a
sub 1 this function so there's no less
extensions so does that tell I guess the
two has two one is how good are the
marginals are single terms or
collections that's still interesting it
what size second this competition can i
compute those so both sides of the
inequality that I showed you can be
tight but first thing of this right but
oh I see you're asking better
can I get better than factor to it by
you say production so yeah so I
currently don't have a way to use low
concavity allow us to to to get anything
about higher-order marginals so that's
also another problem yes if you if you
forget about the computational problem
that's still a barrier I've got a
computational problem
there's Lois extension help
how do you compute the lodge extension
if you don't know how to compute the
higher-order marginal
need to compute for any subset - destiny
that Eliza but you'd only can do four
syllables right yeah you still need or
coin is the fact that complex
yeah I don't know maybe maybe there are
mathematical inequalities you can prove
that are not helpful in computation